president biden gave the order yesterday
to send troops to help evacuate u.s
embassy personnel he maintains the
decision to begin a final withdrawal
from afghanistan earlier this year was
the right one wijajang is at the white
house ouija what is the president saying
about this latest move
good morning vlad president biden hasn't
made any remarks about the evacuation
the details of which were unfolding just
as he was delivering a speech about
prescription drug prices
[Applause]
[Music]
earlier this week though the president
stood by his decision to pull u.s troops
out of afghanistan by the end of this
month insisting afghan forces must fight
for themselves afghan diplomatic sources
told cbs news sending 3 000 troops to
help american diplomats evacuate on
military planes sends a signal that the
afghan government is weak that could
already be having a broader impact with
reports that canada is closing its
embassy in kabul the fall of the city of
ghazni wednesday launched the u.s plan
into motion because of the city's close
proximity to kabul republicans are
pouncing wyoming congresswoman liz
cheney tweeted america's enemies know
that the slogan ending endless war
actually means unconditional surrender
and south carolina senator lindsey
graham said all of this is a result of
president biden believing he knows more
than his military advisers when it comes
to afghanistan the worst is yet to come
the state department said diplomatic
work will continue house speaker nancy
pelosi has requested an all-member's
briefing on afghanistan for the week of
august 23rd when the house is back in
session vlad
all right we thank you very much